I know people will sell
their soul for a lot of money.
Unfortunately, I do think everybody has a price.
Everybody could use a little bit more money.
Times are hard.
You know, money talks. So...
Hey, give me something, I’ll do it.
If I’m gonna do something,
I may as well make a profit.
Wait a minute!
Wait a minute. Wait a minute now.
How much money are we talking about?
Leave dog poop on the sidewalk?
100 bucks.
99 cents.
For 50, maybe I’d look the other way.
I'm going...
5000.
If it's at city Hall, eh...
500.
It's my best friend.
I’d ruin that shit for 500.
20 bucks.
50 dollars.
Like, there's chlorine
in it for a reason.
Enough drinks.
That's what it would take.
You don't need to pay me
as long as I don't get caught.
[laughter]
I would unfollow my best friend for 2 dollars.
Wow, that's like Judas betraying Jesus.
Probably like, a couple thousand.
I have really good posts.
I think I would do it for 100 dollars.
Gross.
Also, who carries a nail clipper?
Specifically for him?
Just a couple hundred bucks.
I guess you can be bought cheaply.
This is a dark, dark, dark interview.
Well, that's something different then.
4.56 million dollars is a
life-changing amount of money.
Oh my god!
Oh, yo!
[collective gasp]